and now a story every family in the
valley needs to hear
a two-year-old girl dies after getting
into a pool
unattended that girl's mother is suing
saying her daughter's death
could have been prevented and failures
in pool safety
are to blame the i-team's david charns
has her story and what every pool owner
needs to know the last thing i said to
my daughter
was and i had her repeat
i am beautiful the way i am angelica
jones will never forget january 31st
2020
the day her two-year-old daughter nevaeh
repeated those words
and hours later died she just slipped
out the house
according to a lawsuit nevaeh was
staying at her father's house
when she got out of a back door threw a
hole in a mesh fence and in the rental
property's pool
she's in the pool
nobody can't really tell me what
happened
she's just in the pool they don't know
how long she was in the full force
according to the lawsuit nevaeh went
down for a nap
at 11 that morning less than an hour
later at 11
40 a family member noticed the back door
was open
finding nevaeh face down in the pool she
was rushed to henderson hospital
but it was too late everything should
have been up to par the coroner's report
about nevaeh's death cited in the
lawsuit and provided to the i-team
says the sliding door to the backyard
does not lock
and the family uses a piece of wood to
secure it it also says while there was a
mesh fence
the gate to the pool area was broken at
the bottom
and nevaeh was able to get under it
those things should be fixed
the lawsuit was filed against the
property owner the management company
nevaeh's father and his fiancee
according to court documents filed by
nevaeh's father
he requested the property owner complete
repairs during move-in four years ago
the filing also says this request was
made many times to the rental company
but no repairs were done they made
numerous requests for
the owner to come and make repairs and
he refused
dennis prince is an helico's attorney he
points to clark county code
requiring properties with pools to
maintain safety standards
including mesh fencing working door
latches and maintaining both of them
henderson also has its own ordinance
requiring
fencing or other barriers for pools to
be properly maintained
if one more death can be prevented
because of this lawsuit then we've
accomplished a greater goal
nevaeh would be three today her mom says
she remembers just how happy her
daughter was to see her dad that day
but she never had a chance to say
goodbye
i didn't get to really hug her the way i
wanted to she
gave me a quick hug and she would not
put her back
according to the cdc 10 people die a day
from drowning here in the u.s
about one in five of those drowning
deaths two a day
are children 14 and younger like nevaeh
i'm david charns 8 news now the i-team
reached out to the attorney representing
the property owner and the property
management company directly
and we did not hear back